he became north korea's leader before
turning 30. at the time many hoped king
jam-un would lead the country into a new
era one that would open the reclusive
nation and its economy to the world
instead kim's decade in power has been
defined by brutal violence
nuclear weapons and meetings with donald
trump it's my honor and
we will have a terrific relationship i
have no
it doubt easy to get here and all
prejudices and practices worked as
obstacles in our way forward but we
overcame all of them and we're here
today
unprecedented meetings to gradually
denuclearize the north in exchange for
sanctions relief ultimately failed and
threats against regional neighbors and
their allies continued
the entire united states is within range
of our nuclear weapons and the nuclear
button is always on my desk
but kim's fixation on nuclear weapons
has come at a heavy price
the united nations and others have kept
tough economic sanctions
north korea has been working towards two
huge goals strengthening national
defense and improving living standards
living situation got worse because of
sanctions and the pandemic
kim's appetite for international respect
has led him to the global stage but his
leadership has been described as
ruthless
with reports of executions including
against his own brother
rivals and dissidents say poverty and
starvation are rampant
to mark 10 years since the death of his
father kim jong-il north koreans were
reportedly banned from laughing drinking
or shopping for 11 days kim now leads a
political dynasty spanning three
generations that few dare question
kim is emulating his grandfather because
many people miss the past so he tried to
look and dress similar to his
grandfather and shed tears while giving
speeches
that's cosplay
[Music]
much is still unknown about the young
leader
including his long-term plans for north
korea
katya lopez
al jazeera